welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's eternal's final
minutes leave the face of the planet and
the cosmos beyond changed forever in the
mcu between half the eternals blasting
off again
and the other half letting sexy space
jesus take the wheel but this ending was
actually one of many originally shot for
the eternal's final act somehow two
hours and 37 minutes was the thin
version of something so i am gonna break
down this eternal's alternate ending and
all of the deleted scenes we know about
including a thanos flashback that might
have given viewers a way deeper
understanding of this film eternal's
theatrical ending features cersei vastos
and kingo being summoned by ayershem for
stopping the emergence of teemut the
eternal arrows greets theena makari and
druid on the domo and says that he knows
where to find cersei but instead of
ending on the perfectly pleasant harry
styles grin they actually shot an
extended version of this final scene
according to makari actor lauren ridloff
in a round table interview with
entertainment weekly arrows actually
then sits down with these eternals and
they all communicate with the celestial
air shem with their eyes closed so in
the way ajax and cersei close their eyes
to commune with aeroshem now eros is
doing the same using presumably a
unimine type function to link makari
athena in druid on that conference call
and this is a major confirmation of what
exactly arose's relationship with the
celestials is before it wasn't entirely
clear which celestial eros was in
communication with eresham or a
different celestial who might be in
conflict with irishm either a
philosophical dispute or a more violent
conflict but now we know that eros was
going to communicate with arashem using
his celestial bluetooth sphere meaning
it was arashem who installed eros and
potentially thanos and their father
alars on the planet titan and this
alternate ending also tells us that
arrows does not fear airship like these
new qualms about linking with their shim
to track aeroshem's location or to try
to talk him out of prosecuting cersei it
means that eros enjoys a kind of
privileged status among eternals
aeroshem did tell cersei that some of
his creations evolved beyond his control
and arrows and thanos might be such
rogue beings now this movie's co-writer
ryan firpo revealed that there were
actually nine versions of this
post-credits scene that they came up
with so the post-credits sequences i can
just say we wrote about nine versions
before we settled on what's in the movie
there are some really spicy ones that
always change they just told different
stories they chose different characters
they introduced different ideas and so a
big part of it for us was just where do
we want to go next and when we finally
figured that out when the movie was done
that's when we knew okay this is the way
we're going and this is we're going out
into the stars and this alternate ending
would have given us a clear context of
how arrows and thanos fit into the
overall hierarchy of cosmic entities
like the celestials the brothers were
essentially on different paths based on
their specific history with ereshim in
fact we've learned of another deleted
scene that the writers revealed a screen
rant that would have flashed back to a
younger thanos on titan according to kaz
ferpo the flashback would have explored
the past version of titan revealed in
thanos reality stone vision in avengers
infinity war and shown its destruction
by quote radical growth in the universe
and that would have been what sent
thanos on his warpath to erase half of
all life this was probably the eternal
scene that thanos creator jim starlin
was referring to when he said that young
thanos would appear in the eternals film
in an interview back in 2020. so this
could mean that the planet titan was
seated with its own sleeping celestial
one that is still buried underneath its
surface because the planet has not
exploded but that despite thanos and
aeros best efforts environmental
collapse caused the planet's intelligent
light to die out before the light force
could reach a critical mass to trigger
its emergence aeros and thanos could be
eternals who failed their mission or
allowed it to fail and broke free of
arashim's protocol in the comics before
gathering the infinity stones thanos
augmented his strength and powers
through a mix of science mysticism and
cybernetic enhancements and it sounds
like this deleted flashback would have
shown thanos and aeros attempts to save
titan from extinction and then failing
that going on to augment their own
powers separate from what the celestials
designed them to do remember earlier in
the eternals film fastos has an
interesting line about the reason ajax
didn't want them to intervene in human
conflict was that wars have historically
led to advancements in tech and medicine
and food production that ultimately in a
roundabout way end up prolonging human
life so maybe on titan thanos and arrows
did initially try to intervene in
certain ways in their wars like that
titan versus cree war that was teased in
loki episode one we actually saw the
same ships in the background as the ones
that we now see crashed on the surface
of titan and that intervention in the
wars caused titan's population growth to
outpace the technological evolution that
would be needed to sustain such a
society you know sometimes these easter
eggs just feel like they were perfectly
designed for you if only all things in
life could be that way like the mattress
we sleep on every night well thanks to
helix you can get a mattress that is
just right for you helix sleep makes
premium mattresses and bedding
customized to fit your needs and shipped
right to your door helix is a sleep quiz
that matches your unique body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you i took the quiz and got
matched with the dusk lux helix mattress
because i wanted a medium firm mattress
with lumbar support that sleeps cool
i've had it for over a year now and i
love it it totally delivers on all the
great features helix delivers your
mattress right to your door for free it
comes rolled up in a surprisingly small
box and it's super easy to set it up
yourself helix has a 100 night sleep
trial so you get more than three months
to make sure that you love it and if you
don't they will pick it up for you and
you'll get a full refund but i love my
helix and i think you're gonna love your
helix too if you're looking for a new
bed check out helix you can click the
link below or go to helixsleep.com
rockstars and get up to 200 off your
helix mattress now there are other
deleted scenes from eternals and lines
that we know about from the trailers
like those shots of athena battling
soldiers in the gupta empire and 400 a.d
in the movie we saw their arrival to
india and of course cersei and ikers's
marriage there but the battle was
removed and interestingly this is a shot
that would have shown that soldier with
that star shield very similar to captain
america's classic design and these same
shield patterns that we see on the set
of kingo's bollywood film and we later
find out that king goes totally obsessed
with captain america because he collects
cap's classic prop shield from the 40s
or at least a replica of it so i'm still
theorizing that bastos may have been
working for howard stark during world
war ii and been the one who hooked him
up with that vibranium for the prototype
shield that he gave to cap and quit only
when the us defense forces bombed
hiroshima and that that design that he
ended up giving to captain america based
off of his suggestions could have at
least been influenced partly by fastos
and maybe kingo and of course there are
a few other lines you may remember from
trailers that were cut from the film
eternals assembled great line this is
what the end of the world looks like at
least we have front row seats hell yes
the avengers thor
spiderman
but we have as well as a shot of sprite
singing karaoke on the jet chloe zhao
also revealed that in the original
script there were going to be 12
eternals not 10 including the journal
from the comics named vampiro who
becomes a pro wrestler with a
batman-esque suit and bat fangs but he's
not actually a vampire he probably could
have afforded to cut a few more of them
the co-writers also told the hollywood
reporter that they wanted to include
more flashbacks to the eternals pasts
throughout history and would love to
potentially explore them further in a
prequel series like can go in 1890s
mumbai juggling his life as a movie star
and then later on dealing with gandhi's
peaceful dissolution of the british
empire in india and then another episode
with theena in greece and then another
episode that follows the eternals
confronting ereshem and all the
celestials the writers also revealed in
the amazing ringer verse eternals deep
dive podcast which i totally recommend
listening to they are amazing that the
writers conceived of an additional
family of eternals that were stationed
on earth connected to ancient egypt and
king arthur maybe a different family of
eternals that's come and they've also
been stationed and they're going to
egypt and they're hanging out with king
arthur meaning that likely among these
writers early drafts of the script were
planned of linking arthurian legend and
excalibur in the ebony blade as dialogue
in this movie clearly points out which
could have given plenty more context to
the black knight's lineage the early
days of eternals which would have
explained why cersei told dane to make
amends with his uncle when the comics is
nathan garrett the previous black knight
not a very good guy so ultimately i
agree that as a story as huge as
eternals it could have worked better as
like a six episode miniseries on disney
plus because i would have loved to have
seen all these deleted scenes but there
was not room for them in this movie
structurally it would have been great to
explore each character in their own
episode on a show on disney plus but on
the other hand we would miss out on a
celestial's immensity and scale
presented on a huge screen which i
suspect is why chloe zhao and kevin
feige wanted to do this as a movie
because kevin feige wanted us to wet
ourselves when we saw these things and
that just you know wouldn't work as well
at home because my couch has already
soaked through my friends bathrooms all
the way across the room i'm not getting
up let me know which of these deleted
scenes you would have most preferred to
see in the eternals film and you can
support this channel by checking out our
great merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow me
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
breakdowns of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
so